[Music]
today's question is from scott in
michigan i have uh now been leading fpu
for several years so i'm well versed on
what the ramsey plan is for a ton of
life situations i now face a dilemma
in my attempt to further my career i
have a lot of big banks mortgage
companies and other such financial
institutions at which i could work i'm
wondering is there a motor excuse me a
moral or ethical issue
with going to work for one of these
institutions since they make their money
by selling debt i'm an i.t so i wouldn't
have any direct involvement in the
business side but it still seems like it
would be a conflict of principle what
are your thoughts well scott in some
ways you answer your own question here
because while it is in fact a dilemma
because of what you believe how you live
your life and how you're teaching others
the ramsey way
this is a dilemma but it is not a moral
ethical issue
period end of end of sentence there's
nothing you're not breaking the law
you are not doing anything that would
even be considered a gray area from an
ethical standpoint however this is a
principle issue and so you've got
principle on one side
and uh you've got a legitimate way to
work you're in i.t and you can make
really good money do very well there but
this is not an ethical issue it is a
principle issue and that's a difference
so you've got to be able to live with
you now there's
let me give you an example what i do on
that okay
i endorse
community banks sure and credit unions
in a lot of cities right a lot of local
radio stations sell ads with my voice
that i endorse and i do believe in them
yeah in community banks and church hill
mortgage a mortgage churchill mortgage
and mike hardwick owns churchill's one
of my best friends yep
and uh so
now what's the difference i wouldn't
endorse bank of america
for any amount of money
i would feel dirty
so the way i answer the question is
would i send
someone there that i care about
because i'm getting ready to send my
listeners there you guys out there
and if i if i would not send someone i
care about there then i don't need to
send anybody there that's hypocritical
would i do i.t work
do you feel dirty when you get home
because of the way that business is
conducted who they are how they do
business the type of products they put
out the door so there's various kinds of
debt products
there's various kinds of banks uh there
are banks like bank of america where
you're a number
all they see you as an opportunity loan
your money so fi
all their all their soft pedaling uh
nurturing bullcrap at marketing is all
about just trying to make you feel
better about them trying to sell you
debt yeah and so i couldn't work for
them i couldn't i certainly wouldn't
endorse them obviously uh you know jp
morgan chase i'm not endorsing so i
don't endorse any big banks but i do
endorse small banks and i tell people
not to borrow money you know isn't that
well you have a checking account there
you have some other things there you
could work in the mortgage business we
tell people not to take out a mortgage
unless it's more than a 15th year and if
you got the money to pay cash pay cash
churchill mortgage goes along with that
so we endorse churchill mortgage right
and have for 25 years so i think you're
fine uh where what it amounts to is are
you being hypocritical yes
and and the way you answer that is what
i send what i send my best friend there
i really like that that's the slime ball
test yeah if they're not a slime ball
then there's no issue you're fine go do
good i.t work if the you know i'm not
working for a payday lender they're
taking advantage of the poor
period and they're not going to be on
any on this show you know ever as long
as i'm breathing you know and that kind
of thing so that that's
you know but that that's uh
you you just
you're right it's morals
ethics and hypocrisy and it is kind of a
grady all the way to principles it is
kind of a gradient
there um you know if you work at pizza
hut and they take visa
yeah you know it doesn't mean that
you're for credit cards and you're
waiting tables are you
violating your financial piece uh when
you raised your right hand said i
promise to never do debt and never do
credit cards as long as i shall live or
whatever the boy scouts honor thing is
right that's right and so you know that
kind of thing hold three fingers
together put them up in the air all that
kind of stuff right so but i don't
borrow money
and so and i teach people this stuff so
if i took credit cards that would be
super bad
right that would be inconsistent i
remember i went to when i first started
this i went to a get out of debt seminar
this guy had and he sold a ton of books
on credit cards at the back table during
the break yeah and i'm like this is so
inconsistent that's correct
and so but uh we take debit cards here
and uh we tell you not to use your
credit card you know it's hypocritical
we do not need your money if you're
borrowing money
to buy our stuff do not borrow money to
buy our stuff that's ridiculous it's you
know the stuff's at the library and you
can listen on for free on youtube and on
this show on your local radio station so
don't go borrow money to do it if you
want to enhance the process and you have
the money by buying a book or going to
financial peace university here using
ken's assessment or reading one of his
books to enhance the process to get a
a thing but you don't need to go in debt
to get a job no no not at all and so
this comes down to again what do i
believe is right for me
versus right and wrong yeah if that's
the you got it if i'm hardcore financial
peace university and i own a restaurant
is it bad for me to take credit cards i
don't think so no not at all but if
you're if you're me and you make your
living doing this that because i tell
people and then if i did that would be
that would be backward you know so um
it's now if you believe you're bringing
harm to someone and you're doing that
intentionally you will in any business
or in any position in any business if
you believe you're participating in that
company doing bad things
or something that's bad for people then
you're gonna have a hard time succeeding
at that it's a because your your brain
is called cognitive dissonance your
brain works against itself
so don't try to do that
i don't care how much money you make
doing scummy things doesn't pay off
psychologically in the long run
that's what it comes down to it's a
great question what a great heart he's
got